au nom de l'assemblée générale j'ai
l'honneur de souhaiter la bienvenue aux
nations unies son excellence monsieur
charles michel président du conseil
européen de l'union européenne et je
l'invite à prendre la parole devant
l'assemblée madame la présidente
monsieur le secrétaire général
excellences mesdames et messieurs les
délais du
nadia mourra tu es né en irak
nadia moore ati 10 et le 15 août 2014 sa
vie va basculer
des djihadistes attaque son village
6 parmi ces frais sont assassinés sous
ses yeux pour la dernière fois elle
verra sa mère ce jour là elle sera
capturé pour devenir une esclave
sexuelle et elle subira les sévices les
plus immondes elle finira par s'échapper
aujourd'hui nadia mourad et prix nobel
de la paix et elle se bat sans relâche
pour les droits et la dignité des femmes
et je veux à cette tribune cité les
propos qu'il a exprimée il ya quelques
jours à peine
aujourd'hui nous voyons le prix des
conflits marqué sur les corps des femmes
en irak en afghanistan dans le tigré et
dans tant d'autres endroits tant de
potentiel et perdu lorsque l'on ignore
le pouvoir des femmes dans la prévention
des conflits et l'influent et la
reconstruction des communautés fin de
citation
mesdames et messieurs j'ai rencontré
nadia mourad j'ai vu dans ses yeux toute
la force de l'humanité j'ai entendu dans
la douceur de sa voix une absolue
détermination
elle a décidé de puiser dans le drame et
dans l'infini souffrance une force
inébranlable pour transformer le monde
pour transformer le monde et c'est
habité par l'inspiration de nadéah
mourad que je m'adresse à vous
aujourd'hui
lévis un djeune mesdames et messieurs
l'union européenne a été forgé par les
européens
comme un sursaut de dignité
après deux guerres mondiales sanglante
aujourd'hui nous faisons face un autre
moment charnière de l'histoire humaine
parce que
nous
[Musique]
subissons les effets d'une autre guerre
une guerre universelle cette guerre
universelle n'oppose ni belligérants ni
armée elle n'en traite elle n'entraîne
pas de conquête de territoires et
pourtant cette guerre universelle prises
dvi elle détruit des territoires et elle
fait souffrir des familles de manière
inimaginable mesdames et messieurs
je parle de la guerre que nous l'espèce
humaine avant déclenchée contre la
nature en perpétrant des tortures sur
notre environnement en abusant de ses
ressources naturelles en maltraitant nos
forêts et nos océans ce sont des actes
de guerre que nous avons déclenché et la
nature réagit elle se retourne contre
eux contre contre nous elle nous
rappelle à la raison et à l'humilité
personne ne peut dire nous ne savions
pas pour l'eau depuis longtemps pendant
des décennies les scientifiques nous
nous avertissent mais nous avons fait la
sourde oreille nous avons choisi de
tourner la tête pour ne pas voir et
aujourd'hui le choc est brutal
nous récoltons ce que nous avons semé
les incendies qui ont dévasté
l'australie et sécheresses qui ont
ravagé l'afrique les inondations qui ont
marqué l'europe et les ouragans qui ont
saccagé les états unis
et c'est un autre il y à un autre fléau
planétaire également président par la
science qui nous a ravagé qui nous
ravagent depuis bientôt deux ans lakovic
19 qui a tué aveuglément 4,5 millions de
personnes et a brisé la vie de millions
de personnes mais cette pandémie nous a
également ramené à l'essentiel la vie et
la dignité humaine
nous avons pris des décisions hors du
commun pour les protéger des confinement
massif qui nous ont qui ont mis nos
économies nos vies sociales et plus
grave encore nos libertés pratiquement à
l'arrêt et cette pandémie nous a aussi
ouvert les yeux
sur nos vies
sur notre santé nos vies et notre santé
sont inextricablement inextricablement
liés à la santé de nos champs de nos
forêts de nos océans et des faunes qui
les peuplent nous partageons cette
planète avec d'autres êtres vivants et
le moment est venu d'arrêter de mener
cette guerre déclenchée contre contre la
nature nous devons y mettre faire
maintenant à nous espèce humaine de
poser l'acte d'armistice d'offrir un
traité de paix à la nature et aux
générations qui nous suivent à nous de
transformer le monde comme
nos aînés l'ont fait au lendemain de la
dernière guerre mondiale
inspiré par les signataires visionnaire
de la charte des nations unies
le moment est venu de revenir à
l'essentiel la raison et le discernement
inspiré par ses principes
ils nous ont légué un ordre
international fondé sur des règles pour
promouvoir la paix ils ont bâti des
démocraties libérales pour garantir la
dignité de chacun
ils ont porté un modèle de développement
basé sur la liberté d'entreprendre et
d'échangés
pour assurer la prospérité
et ses choix
ont amené du progrès davantage de
stabilité
mes le monde de diers n'est pas celui
d'aujourd'hui
et encore moins celui de demain
mesdames et messieurs
mesdames et messieurs les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement excellence l'unil et
un réalisme brutal prend trop souvent le
pas sur la proche multilatérale les
ambitions de domination créer de
nouvelles dépendances et provoque des
tensions et des conflits
les démocraties sont sous pression de
l'intérieur ou de l'extérieur
des régimes autoritaires masqué ou non
mines méticuleusement les principes de
liberté chez eux mêmes chez les autres
enfin
notre modèle de développement économique
est à bout de souffle
ces failles sont de plus en plus visible
l'exploitation extrême des ressources et
l'accroissement des inégalités
constitue un cercle vicieux dont nous
devons sortir excellences mesdames et
messieurs
nous sommes bien à un moment charnière
et nous devons nous poser une question
quel monde voulons nous pour demain
nous voulons un monde inspiré par la
raison un monde qui fait confiance à la
science qui garantit la dignité et la
liberté de chaque être humain nous
voulons un monde plus juste et plus sûr
nous voulons la coopération plutôt que
la confrontation
nous voulons la solidarité plutôt que le
repli sur soi nous voulons la
transparence plutôt que l'opacité et
nous voulons la loyauté
plutôt que le mépris de la parole donnée
elle faisait messieurs
vous pouvez compter sur l'union
européenne
en soutenant la wna 2030 et les
objectifs du développement durable est
en pleine confiance avec deux stages
nalut rs à nom de plus juste c'est un
monde nous sommes tous protégés du que
vides 19 l'union européenne a souhaité
soutenir massivement la recherche et
développer des capacités importantes de
production des vaccins nous avons
exporté 700 millions de doses dans 130
pays et 3 milliards d'euros ont été
investis dans kovacs nous devons le
reconnaître
l'écart de vaccination à des pays en
développement n'est pas acceptable et
nous devons agir tout lui de
heureusement encore nous avons lancé des
projets concrets un milliard d'euros a
été mobilisée pour développer des
capacités de production pharmaceutique y
compris vaccinale dans plusieurs pays
africains et nous sommes aussi prêts à
soutenir des partenariats en amérique
latine enfin nous savons qu'ils ne
suffira pas de vaincre cette pandémie si
il faudra prévenir les prochaines et
renforcer la résilience du monde entier
et c'est l'objectif du traité
international sur les pandémies nous
avons proposé avec docteur tedros
débrayé zus les emplois ici chacun à
soutenir au plus vite le lancement des
négociations
un monde plus juste un monde plus sûr
c'est aussi un monde libéré de la menace
climatique
il nous faut des objectifs ambitieux
l'accord de paris a été une étape
majeure et l'union européenne a été un
acteur de poids
contrairement à d'autres nous avons tenu
bon pour défend cet accord et les 27
chefs d'état du gouvernement il ya deux
ans ont montré le chemin en prenant
l'engagement de la neutralité plus
claire de la neutralité climat en 2050
pour l'union européenne d'autres suivent
cet exemple et dans ce même esprit ni
européenne a décidé de rehausser ses
objectifs à l'horizon 2030 on doit bien
sûr progresser dans la coopération
internationale nous pensons que nous
devons aller vers la tarification du
carbone nous l'avons entamée à notre
niveau
le système d'échangé d'émissions ets
parce que nous pensons que cette
approche stimule
l'innovation trop des résultats et
encourage l'économie circulaire ensuite
bien sûr il est impératif de développer
davantage des investissements dans le
verdissement de l'économie et nous
souhaitons pouvoir développer des
approches globales pour fixer un cadre
réglementaire la finance verte enfin
dans cette assemblée nous le savons tous
le monde n'est pas égal dans la course
contre la montre du réchauffement les
pays développés porte une responsabilité
particulière pour accompagner les pays
en développement et depuis la promesse
en 2009 et 2010 de mobiliser 100
milliards de la annuel pour financer la
lutte internationale contre le
réchauffement rares sont ceux qui ont
tenu parole de 2013 à 2019 l'union
européenne et les états membres ont
versé 127 milliards d'euros c'est un
tiers du total et nous engageons les
autres partenaires eux aussi à tenir
leurs promesses c'est une question de
confiance c'est une question d'équité
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs un monde plus
juste il ya un monde plus sûr c'est
aussi un monde en paix en ce moment même
des femmes sont brutalisés sont violées
parce qu'elles sont des femmes et sept
armes de guerre est notamment utilisé
dans la corne d'afrique en ethiopie nous
appelons à un cessez le feu est à
l'arrêt immédiat des violences ethniques
l'accès à l'aide humanitaire va être
garantie sans aucune entrave
la pauvreté le radicalisme sont deux
fléaux qui se nourrissent mutuellement
l'éducation les services de base la
santé les infrastructures sont le savons
les meilleurs remèdes contre
l'instabilité et entre les dangers qui
sont liées au sein l'union européenne et
neuf de nos états membres sont mobilisés
auprès des populations pour des raisons
de sécurité de défense et pour l'aide au
développement
mais bien sûr restaurer l'autorité de
l'état garantit la gouvernance sont
indispensables pour engranger des
résultats durables
l'oms et messieurs chers collègues
la situation nouvelle en afghanistan est
un échec pour la communauté
internationale
et des enseignements doivent en être
tirées mais une chose est sûre la fin
d'opération militaire n'est pas la fin
de l'engagement européen
auprès des afghanes et des afghans nous
voulons éviter toute catastrophe
humanitaire
préserver autant que possible les acquis
des 20 dernières années spécialement
pour les droits des femmes et des jeunes
filles
dans la région 1 2 pacifique l'union
européenne est le premier investisseur
est l'un des plus importants partenaires
commerciaux
40% de notre commerce y transitent et
nous avons décidé d'y renforcer
massivement notre coopération c'est le
sens du partenariat désormais
stratégique avec l'asian la sécurité et
la liberté de navigation en mer de chine
méridionale et dans l'océan indien
doivent être garantis conformément au
droit international et l'union
européenne est prête à y prend sa pleine
part de responsabilité
mesdames et messieurs
jamais l'union européenne ne baissera
les yeux face aux violations des droits
humains
l'état de droit la non-discrimination
le respect des minorités y compris lgbt
d'hui sont des valeurs cardinales et
c'est le sens du dialogue droits de
l'homme que nous menons avec de nombreux
pays dans le monde nous défendons
fermement nos valeurs mais bien sûr nous
sommes prêts aussi à être engagés à
dialoguer afin de relever les défis
globaux comme le climat la biodiversité
ou la lutte pour les pandémies
la paix
c'est bien plus que l'absence de la
guerre
la paix n'est jamais acquise elle se
fractionne au quotidien elle se nourrit
par les collections mutuelle entre nos
sociétés et plus nous partageons
d'intérêt mois nous entrons en conflit
les échanges économiques scientifiques
culturel intellectuel son déferrement
puissant pour la stabilité et cela passe
par les projets d'intégration régionale
ou continentale
cela passe aussi par les grands
partenariats entre ces nouveaux espaces
intégrés que ce soit en amérique latine
et aux caraïbes en asie et aussi en
afrique
avec nos frères africains nous
travaillons d'arrache-pied pour une
nouvelle alliance avec le continent
africain
écoute respect mutuel prise en compte
des spécificités des réalités
transparence gouvernance de part et
d'autres doivent en être la marque de
fabrique nous mobiliserons les secteurs
privés pour investir dans les
infrastructures et les nouvelles
technologies nous soutiendrons tous les
efforts pour promouvoir l'éducation
parce que l'éducation c'est le plus sur
le vix pour offrir un avenir meilleur
nos intérêts communs sont un moteur
robuste pour faire réussir le nouveau
logiciel de notre partenariat
dames et messieurs l'union européenne et
nos états membres sommes une des
principales puissances économiques dans
le monde et nous sommes aussi le premier
sponsor de la paix et du développement
durable nous finançons avec les états
membres un quart du budget de
l'organisation des nations unies 30 % du
budget total de maintien de la paix et
la moitié de l'inde au développement
mondial c'est un choix délibéré et c'est
un choix cohérent avec notre vision du
monde ouvert et interconnectés nous
avons des valeurs à promouvoir des
citoyens à protéger des intérêts à
défendre et c'est dans cet esprit que
nous développons l'autonomie stratégique
de l'union européenne y compris dans nos
capacités de sécurité et de défense pour
être moins dépendants pour renforcer
notre influence positive et aussi pour
consolider notre alliance atlantique
cette alliance qui est ancré dans nos
valeurs démocratiques et qui est un
pilier inébranlable
de notre sécurité et de la stabilité
dans le monde des alliés plus fort fonte
une alliance plus forte dans la
transparence et la loyauté
notre influence positive nous voulons
bien entendu aussi l'approfondir dans
notre voisinage immédiat c'est le sens
du partenariat oriental qui est un
engagement de long terme avec l'ukraine
la géorgie la moldavie l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
c'est aussi le sens notre soutien à la
population dès la russe et de notre
fermeté vis-à-vis du régime de monsieur
de loukachenko notamment lorsqu'il tente
d'instrumentaliser les migrants comme
arme hybride pour déstabiliser des
membres de l'union européenne
enfin c'est le sort du travail que nous
effectuons afin de resserrer les liens
avec les pays des balkans occidentaux
le récent regain de violence au proche
orient a été un nouveau rappel de la
nécessité absolue de reprendre le
dialogue pacifique vers la solution à
deux états entre israël et la palestine
mesdames et messieurs chers collègues
transformer le monde
le rendre plus juste et plus sûr
garantir la dignité de chacun voilà la
promesse voilà le serment des nations
unies il nous appartient à tous d'être à
la hauteur cet engagement de cette
ambition pour tout les nadia mourra de
ce monde et pour les générations qui
vont nous suivre vous pouvez compter sur
l'union européenne
je vous remercie
au nom de l'assemblée générale je tiens
à remercier le président du conseil de
l'union européenne pour l'allocution qui
vient de prononcer je prie le protocole
de bien vouloir accompagner son
excellence